in this episode of the secret manager
video series
we'll talk about global secret names and
regional replication policies
should you choose user managed or
automatic
stay tuned to find out
[Music]
in secret manager secret names are
project
global resources this is because secrets
rarely differ across cloud regions
as a concrete example your twilio or
twitter api key doesn't
change when you move your application
from us east 1 to europe west 4.
this is different from other google
cloud resources which have a tighter
coupling to a particular region or
geography
for example in google compute engine
virtual machine instances are bound and
referenced by the zone in which they're
created
even though the secret's name is a
project global resource
the secret's payload is still stored
regionally
this means that a secret is globally
addressable by a single name
but the underlying secret material is
still stored in particular regions
payload storage may be an important
concern for regulated customers
or for customers that have strict
requirements over where their data is
stored
like banking fintech or healthcare other
customers may prefer to have their data
stored closer to where they plan to
access it
to minimize latency but how do you
choose the regions in which the secret
payloads are stored
google secret manager features
replication policies
which give you the freedom to choose how
and where
your secret payload is stored to tell us
a little bit more about replication
policies
i think we need to bring in an expert
hey colin thanks for joining us today
hey seth thanks for having me
so colin is a software engineer working
on google secret manager
okay colin earlier i was telling our
viewers about data storage and
regionalization of secrets
could you tell us a little bit more
about secret manager's replication
policies
sure seth replication policies offer
control over where your secret payloads
are stored
some enterprises want full control over
the regions in which the secrets are
stored
while others don't have a preference
secret manager
addresses both of these customer
requirements and preferences with
replication policies
if you don't care about where your
payload is stored you should choose an
automatic replication policy
with automatic replication google cloud
chooses the best regions to replicate
your secret payload
this strategy also offers the highest
availability guarantees
for accessing and creating secrets okay
colin
but which regions does secret manager
pick if i choose
automatic replication that's explicitly
unspecified behavior seth
you should interpret automatic as i
don't care
um but what if i do care what if i care
too much
about where my secret payload is stored
then you should choose user managed
replication policies
with user managed replication you choose
one or more regions to which to
replicate your secret payloads
yeah but then i'm going to have to run
some cloud function that replicates my
secret payload and
i have to deal with all the monitoring
and the alerting and the paging then
actually just like actually you won't
user managed is more like
user selected you pick the regions and
secret manager automatically handles the
replication
oh that's super cool i'm just gonna
replicate my secret payload
into all the available google cloud
regions that's going to give me the most
availability and the lowest latency
thanks colin well and be careful with
that
what why is that while replicating a
secret payload to every region
improves the reliability of accessing a
secret it may decrease the reliability
of adding a secret version
ah okay that makes sense
wait um no that that doesn't make sense
why is that
well in order to add a secret version
all of the regions you select
must be operational if you choose a lot
of regions
and any single one of those regions is
down you can no longer add a new secret
version
i see so depending on my application i
can choose to balance my read
availability and my write availability
accordingly
exactly so how many regions should i
choose colin
well as you mentioned it's heavily
dependent on the application
as a general recommendation you should
choose at least two
but no more than five regions
awesome thanks colin no problem seth
okay let's look at how we set a secrets
replication policy from the google cloud
console
first we choose the secret's name
initial payload
and then we have the option of selecting
regionalization
notice that the default behavior is
automatic
since that's what most customers will
choose if i want to select specific
regions i can check the box
and pick the replicated regions from the
menu
i can also set replication policies from
the command line
using the gcloud tool or from the api
using
any of the secret manager sdks for net
go java php node
python and ruby google secret manager's
flexible replication policies give you
choice over where your secrets are
stored
if you don't have specific
regionalization requirements
choose the automatic replication policy
but if you do have specific
regionalization requirements
pick the user managed replication policy
with specific regions
for even more tips and tricks with
google secret manager
subscribe to google cloud platform
you